it's happened I've got the gold iPhone
at this point it doesn't even matter
because the things that I have gone
through to get this phone it's just been
unbelievable if you've been following my
adventures on Twitter you already know
so we're not gonna rehash that but the
gold iPhone is now officially mine look
at me look at this excitement actually
got into kind of a little fight with a
guy the Apple Store I was like it's not
you in that girl he's like a skull at I
was like no it's not even that gold look
at that mob it's champagne champagne I
did it I did it I'm thinking of doing
another what's on my iPhone but I would
like some suggestions on some things
that you guys think that I should
download I've got all of the usual
suspects
candy crush Instagram Twitter the real
question is what new apps should I get
I'm kind of bored I'd like some new
social networks to join I mean let's
just join a mall it's kind of like
Pokemon that I've never played but I
hear you gotta catch em all I'm also
wearing a little something special for
the occasion
I've got this fantastic gold so I've
never done a wall twerk before I've seen
many on YouTube so I think I know what
to do so I thought that maybe to
celebrate I will try a gold pants gold
iPhone Walt work
I know twerking is really not cool
anymore but don't care I'm bringing
twerking back yeah Miley bring it girl I
ain't as fit as you but I'll do what I
want
pardon my lighting go out here here on
the internet when I watch the video I'm
gonna do this ahh okay
alright I'm gonna give it one more try
am i doing the right yeah twerk minutes
working towards winter I'm gonna leave
twerkin to professionals like Tyler
Oakley and Miley Cyrus so good on you
guys I quit